our voicemail number is two one nine two
david p got a voicemail about the race
and IQ debate that was very interesting
take a listen to this our david i just
want to call in and ask oh well as i
messiness i just remembered you did a
video on IQ basically just uh exposing
the myths of it in the false arguments
but and i don't know if you bring this
up specifically but asians pertaining
asians they usually do generally
speaking better than most races and all
right is they'll use this oftentimes to
bring up why why america's not racist
because asians using do better they have
higher IQs so I was just answer to
interested to see how you combat this
and what are you against this thank you
but I don't even know what the argument
is I guess but the caller is saying is
race so-called race realists claim that
America isn't racist because Asians have
high IQs I mean number one I would say
what evidence do we have that they have
high IQs because they're Asian right
like that that's fundamental question
number one and we talked about that with
Eric Tara Kaymer but if someone asked me
to argue about
I'd probably walk I'd opt out of that
conversation I don't even know what the
argument is well it's so rock solid
you can argue against I would
immediately shut down I wouldn't know
how to argue against it we've got a
great bonus show today become a member
at WWJ ENCOM don't miss the bonus show
because it's a good one